christopher hitchens what are you
reading on this good friday
passover my attention was caught today
um
by a nasty story on the front of the
washington post
world news section about the regional
cold war in
south asia between india and pakistan
which is gradually going nuclear
and i read through it i'm looking for a
tie-in with a story i read last week
about how
the united states congress has
overridden the pressler amendment in
order to supply pakistan with an
enormous
quantity of american weapons in spite of
the fact that it refuses to certify that
it's not going
nuclear and that the tie-in wasn't there
i wish it had been there was a much
better story
about another regional cold war by ray
bonner in the new york times
last friday a week ago today about the
way that greece and turkey are rearming
for war on a massive scale
both of them being armed by the united
states
to the tune of six billion in one case
and four billion in the other two
countries that really can't afford this
byron york do you
pay attention to stories like this not
as much as i should why
uh because it seems like it's taken all
of my time just keeping up with
clinton's scandals and you picked this
morning
for your story uh this one from the new
york times it's on the new york times on
page 22. it's called uh
day of barbs and smirks in a whitewater
trial and it's about
uh cross-examination of the
prosecution's star witness against uh
mcdougalls and gem guy tucker and
the the odd thing about the time story
is is what you didn't read a few days
ago a few days ago
the witness david hale made his
allegation finally under oath that
the president had uh had pressured him
to take this 300 000
loan front page of the washington post
it was absolutely nowhere to be found in
the new york times
so they print the rebuttal when the
rebuttal to the witness comes out
it makes it into the paper when the
original allegation came out it was
nowhere to be found
what was your next story that you chose
today the next story i chose was
a theater review in the new york times
theater review there's been a revival of
a wonderful play
which was also a very interesting film
um called um
inherit the wind it's about the scopes
trial of uh
sometimes known as the monkey trial in
tennessee
50 years or so ago why is this of
interest to you because
it's more than 50 years such isn't it
since glanced area was on the stand
shows my age
um because in tennessee they're trying
to do it again
they've just passed a statute saying um
that you can be dismissed as a teacher
if you
if you instruct your pupils that
evolution is a scientific matter rather
than a matter of
of debate between evolution and what
they now call which i think is a laugh
intelligent design instead of
creationism you should see the faces by
the way of those who think
that they are the result of an
intelligent design and
uh they've also mandated that the ten
commandments be displayed
in all public offices in tennessee
and i just thought it would go shows her
plus charge but it'd be very good if the
player was a hit and got put on
everywhere else because people can see
exactly what happens when these sorts of
ideas are exposed to a fair test
now byron york chose an entirely
different story again on the federal
page the washington post
called at the justice department big
government keeps getting bigger and
bigger in this age of
reinventing government when the clinton
administration says it is down
sizing government they've asked for a 20
increase in the justice department
budget and
as a matter of fact the budget's gone up
600 percent in the past 16 years most of
that under republicans
and there's a huge patchwork quilt of
federal enforcement agencies uh fbi atf
ins customs dea all overlapping
and uh they're people are beginning to
get worried they're just too darn many
and they're not
coordinated enough now uh mr hitchens
have you seen this
there's a picture of you in here this is
the washington times
and they have you here this looks like
it's at a party of some kind i have no
you have no idea do you no none none
isn't it interesting we can surprise you
with this
insider bash proves great investment
this is something that you put on
it's a book about writ called risky
business by elizabeth
uh lucifer very good book and what are
you
you're talking to uh uh in this picture
diana mcclellan
yes two brits yes old enemy of mine no
there's a very good book by a woman who
was um
conned by lloyds of london um
into becoming a name as they call it you
put your name down as prestige matter
you
you become an underwriter um but you uh
alas you you also become liable they
don't tell you that [ __ ]
here's diana mcclellan and michael
barone
uh who is donna mcclellan by the way you
say an old enemy of yours yeah
john mcclellan used to write a terrible
gossip column called the ear in the
washington post and then
wrote it even worse in the washington
times later on
an enemy of your earth when she wrote a
show a book called iran washington which
i gave a bad review and she chose
actually this very evening
to have her revenge on me in her
introductory speech 14 years she'd
waited to revenge herself for a bad
review i gave her just goes to show
i mean the town remembers well it's
flattering to think that you know
someone's reading you
even if it even if they only read you
when it's about yourself can i also
quickly look at the picture
certainly you haven't seen that you know
it's coming because if i look even more
sorted than i do this morning how
long ago was this picture taken monday
night this was
in one of the one of washington's better
uh
joints it's a bar especially consecrated
to martinis and cigars
uh byron york let me show you a tony
auth cartoon from
this is this morning in the philadelphia
inquirer see it up there on your screen
nixon strolling on the beach great photo
ops in history lbj exhibits his scar
dukakis in the tank and dole relaxing in
florida
any reaction maureen dowd told the story
about the
dole photo the other day in the new york
times and and the
story she told was that an ap stringer
posed as a vacationer came up
while dole was was relaxing and
took his photo went back to the ap and
said well you need dole's permission to
run it
went back to dole admitted her ruse and
dole said fine run it
so if that story is true at least it
wasn't uh planned by the campaign
to show off his vigor any comment just
shows how
the how uh this campaign is it seems to
me
i mean to be assigned to the putative or
presumptive
republican nominee and to have
absolutely nothing to write about
at all imagine how what a miserable job
it must be
and see what it says about the fact that
this is a campaign with no politics no
issues no no excitement no interest for
anyone at all and with
months to run have either one of you
seen this story leading the los
angeles times this morning u.s okayed
iran arms for bosnia i just saw your
discussion of it earlier today
president clinton secretly gave a green
light to covert iranian arms shipments
into bosnia in 1994 despite
a united nations arms embargo that the
united states was pledged to uphold in
the administration's own policy
of isolating tehran globally as a
supporter of terrorism according to
senior
administration officials and other
sources it's jim james risen
and doyle mcmanus development masters
the bureau chief of los angeles times
reaction i wrote a very good book or
co-wrote with jane mayer a very good
book on the iran contra affair darwin
manos
and knows what he's talking about so i
imagine the story is true it drives me
as ridiculous because
one of the arguments that those of us
who favored lifting the arms embargo
always used to make was look if you keep
the bosnians under embargo which is
hopelessly unfair because it locks in
the imbalance between them and the serbs
they will turn to fundamentalist regimes
for their weaponry so one reason to lift
the embargo is so the iranians don't
become
the opportunist agents in the matter and
now
as well as keeping the embargo on we
find the united states administration
was
inciting iran to break it so it seems
um they managed as so often in the their
balkan policy to contrive the worst of
both worlds
blaine harden was here from the
washington post he says this is an
important story
well it's certainly a way to get
something done without actually doing it
i mean that's the
the whole thing about it they they could
not simply take the the united states
government simply
couldn't take the action of doing it
they let somebody else do it does it
talk about what the source of those arms
uh is you mean the iranian arms
we didn't sell them to them did we i've
read most of the piece and didn't see
any reference to that
it says it's suggesting here that the
source of this doesn't say the source of
the story but the cia was the most
unhappy they found out about this
by using their spy satellites watching
the arms come in from turkey so they
were out of the loop on this
and it made it way it made its way to a
reporter
but i wish i had thought of making that
point i mean as with this
story i mentioned earlier india pakistan
and greece and turkey
the american press often writes about
the international arms bazaar as if the
united states wasn't its chief armorer
and chief patron and chief manufacturer
i mean as if in fact the united states
economy wasn't in many ways a war
economy the fact that's so big that it
never gets mentioned
william carly has a story in today's
wall street journal
cbs comma breaking unabomber story
comma forced fbi to move in on suspect
and i read a little bit of it as fbi
agents closed in on the unabomber
suspect in a remote montana cabin dan
rather of cbs news broke into afternoon
programming to announce that the 17-year
manhunt was nearing an end
quote the fbi is preparing to execute a
search warrant unquote on the home of
the unbomber suspect cbs news washington
correspondent jim stewart said shortly
after 3 pm
eastern standard time on wednesday what
cbs didn't say
colin breaking the story forced the
federal bureau of investigation to
terminate its surveillance
of theodore john kashinsky
the former mathematics professor who is
the unabomber suspect
fbi agents hurriedly arranged to
question the 53 year old suspect and
search his lincoln montana cabin a
process that agents normally prefer to
take time and care and planning
this is on page two does it belong there
oh yeah
it's um it was kind of an interesting
story
cbs's story was almost drowned in the
ron brown thing incidentally i mean they
were going to have this big exclusive
it goes on to say they knew about it
since monday and the fbi asked him to
please hold off
and they only ran with it not because
the fbi was about to go in but because
they found out that cnn and
abc knew about it and they might get
scooped on it so they decided to
to go and story says a number of people
in the fbi are unhappy about it but
on the other hand cbs knew the story
they had it enough to report it and they
should have recorded it
comment mr hitchens not really
that important don't know why it doesn't
excite me something
i'll be i'll be more exciting on some
other matter
we have uh we have an article here by mr
york called bum of the month if you're
not a swank celeb
michael lewis hates you who's michael
lewis michael lewis is a
writer he writes he's been writing
political coverage for the new republic
lately
and he as he began his campaign journal
i read the first few and it just kind of
ticked me off so i
i wrote that article about him he made
made quite a bit of fun of phil graham
and some of the rural supporters of
republicans out in
iowa and in new hampshire so i
contrasted that to a story he wrote in
the new republic
about trying to get a summer home
and believing or having his real estate
agent tell him that the actor ron silver
owned the summer home
next door and he relates his tremendous
excitement
and his wife's excitement and they go
almost a year
wondering how they could approach the
great man and be nonchalant and friendly
and approach
ron silver they finally find out that
some guy named david silver owns it no
relation no nothing and they've been
excited for a year for no reason so
i kind of contrasted the way he loved
the celebrity and uh hated the people um
do you know michael lewis yes what do
you what do you think of mr york
well i i liked lewis's campaign coverage
at any rate i mean
i can't remember now the name of the
republican outsider who he made famous
so he obviously didn't make him all that
famous
he was oh funny about the sky morrow
trailer the the
tycoon who failed to get any delegates
uh but who seems like
he made him seem like a very likable and
attractive person and i i thought
generally speaking his courage was good
on the campaign um i remember the ron
silver
diary though did i remember feeling
piercingly embarrassed
mr york writes about the new republican
michael lewis you write about
uh somewhat about ruth shalit and the
new republic and other things called
plagiarism what's this about and when
when are we going to see it in vanity
fair
this is my my next uh fantasy class it's
called
column in vanity fair and it's called
steal this article because it's um
a title to my friend toby young uh
because it's a defense of plagiarism
i thought it was high time someone said
a good word for this and
i maintain that plagiarism is really
indispensable for literary production
as well as for almost all journalistic
production and
it can be a great source of creativity i
distinguish it from
vulgar theft from sort of shoplifting or
or
um kleptomania just simply lifting other
people's senses and putting them in your
own but i
i put the case of t.s eliot of martin
luther king
and of a scottish poet called hugh
mcdermott and show that
all of their best stuff had to be based
on other people's
but the justification um
was that they synthesized it and put it
out at a higher level
and that's a good and necessary thing
if you say you're against plagiarism
which most people say they are
you're saying you can tell what it is
and to say you can tell what it is means
you have to
claim to know what the original is and
also what is authentic
and i maintain that's harder to harder
to know than most people believe
well they at least took the trouble to
rearrange the words and the problem with
uh shalit's
stuff is it been on a number of
occasions there appear to be
whole sentences that were lifted from
other people's stuff and also the
authors are alive and well and living in
washington so they pointed it out well i
mean
uh i think she gambled that um i mean
imagine stephen
he's forbidden to land i think in canada
and australia
um he's prohibited immigration various
other countries
i think it's a i think it's a pity
that this is the case i think these laws
would this country be unconstitutional
and i don't like
uh the way in which the book's been been
mobbed up and i don't like the way that
simone's press gives in not because of
the textbook because of public opinion
it's a very bad sign
byron york is a birmingham alabama
native and christopher hitchen is
originally from portsmouth hampshire
england or is it how do you say that
hampshire hampshire hampshire
whitesboro new york go ahead please yeah
i was gonna ask these two reporters why
they think
our leftist liberal president has not
taken on mr farrakhan
like he would take on mr david dukes
uh it seems to me he's very one-sided
and i think he's afraid of losing the
black vote
in november uh i'd like an answer from
both these men
and please don't soft-soak this answer
byron york
i think the answer is what's in it for
him to come out and denounce uh
dennis farrakhan he can let the he can
go with the people who
agree with the good things that
farrakhan says and just try to hide from
fair can say something off the wall when
he refers to the president as a leftist
liberal does that
does that track for you you think he's a
leftist liberal
it's hard to tell i i think he is in his
heart he's been kind of all over the
place and he's done a pretty good job at
trying to appropriate
some republican ideas lately but sure i
think if he were
in office not worried about reelection
he would come out as a pretty left
liberal guy
let me ask both of you so if the
audience hasn't caught up to date with
your views on this
characterize how you feel about bob bill
and bill clinton
right now about each one of them they're
like two sides are the same
what should we say
they're like two haunches of the same
rear end um
do you like either one of them would you
vote for either one of them i would not
vote for
mr york i like bob bill i think he'd be
a good president i think
this is things would be much different
if bob bill had been president all these
things that were vetoed would not have
been vetoed they would have been passed
and
they will be passed if dole is the
president so he'll sign their stuff
i just feel like oh the first caller an
answer because he was so he was so sure
that
you know that he'd asked such a tough
question that we couldn't possibly face
certainly of course mr clinton is not a
leftist or a level he's
a self-proclaimed and obvious
neo-conservative
second um he has at all occasions i know
about including occasions where no one
asked him to do so
been very hostile to anything that could
be described as black nationalism went
out of his way
if you remember to pick a fight with
sister soldier the rap singer the
rainbow coalition meeting
uh so it's ridiculous to suggest that he
he's going soft on farrakhan
certainly um as far as the black word's
concerned farrakhan doesn't believe in
elections and doesn't think there's
anything to vote for so i don't think
that has anything to do with um
mr clinton solicited for the black vote
in other words which goes to the
democratic party no matter what the
democratic party does to african
americans
but i would like to just like to say
that there is a film going on that i've
been trying to promote in my nation
column
called brother minister it's a film
about the assassination of malcolm x
and it contains an extraordinary piece
of footage a video of
mr farrakhan speaking in his mosque in
chicago more or less in this
as far as i can see actually taking
credit for the murder
of malcolm x and i think this film
should be more widely distributed than
it so far has been having difficulty um
getting a distributor if anyone wants to
contact me i have i have a number
uh through which they can order it
let me um let me just tell our audience
what's coming up we're going to go back
to the navy memorial
uh down on pennsylvania avenue in a
little less than an hour
and then at 9 30 east coast time which
is about uh an hour and a half away
connie broad will join us our executive
producer on this program we want to
listen to you
for suggestions ideas you might have for
the western journal whether you like or
dislike anything that you
see here in the morning you can fax this
and we'll also use those
before we grab and we're going to talk
to our our high school
student of the morning first vote
someone who's voting for the first time
remember who you voted for the first
time
yes i do what year 1976
and gerald ford don't blame me for
carter
you can't vote no i haven't voted for a
long time i'm one of those unlucky
people who
was um when i was 18 there were no votes
at 18 and by the time i was
21 i sort of missed a chance to vote i
remember i virtually for the labor
candidate but that was in england
our our student of the morning is jason
connor
of the edmond memorial high school in
edmond oklahoma good morning mr connor
are you there mr connor yes good morning
good morning
are you are you a senior uh yes sir how
old are you
18. have you registered yes i have
what party democrat why
um well i'm a jewish student living in
uh oklahoma the which of course is the
middle of the
of the bible belt and i've studying
in my limited study of the political
parties i've
kind of figured that uh the democrats
are
more in favor of uh religious freedom if
uh if you will uh the you know with
buchanan
of course uh he's uh with the you know
it begin with the christian coalition
and
wanting to you know not to
take away the separation of church and
state i just uh
clinton has you know he might not have
done the best job but i'd
i think i'd like to just see him in
there for another four years and see who
else we can get in for the
uh republicans i understand that uh
you've traveled to israel that you're
entering
interested in archaeology that uh you
remember the young democrats
and that you paged you were a page in
both the oklahoma house and senate what
when did you do that
i was a page in the oklahoma house
a month ago exactly and i was a page in
the senate
last year a week after the murrah
building bombing
i believe that was the now the
president's going to be in oklahoma city
today
uh yes sir i believe so are you going to
go
no i uh i think it's
it was gonna be pretty tough to get uh
access to it he was i think he
he wasn't gonna make a it very public
this time i think he was coming to
dedicate a building but
uh he wouldn't he wasn't gonna uh
do that until later he was just i think
coming to meet with me with people today
let me go back to you you say you're
you're uh your religion is jewish
yes sir uh do you feel any anti-semitism
living in oklahoma
um a little not not so much uh
like the like anti-semitism from nazi
germany
with you know the wanting to for say
destroy the jewish people but yes
there's
uh there's you know my school is very
you know predominantly christian and it
it makes it difficult
sometimes i mean you can you can feel a
little tension not not
against being jewish but just because
i'm not christian
either one i'm going to ask you our
guests here any comments on anything uh
mr conor has said or questions you might
have for him
do you how old are your children uh
alexander will be 12.
in american citizen yes mr yorkshire
father of three americans
how how big is uh your school and uh mr
connor and
edmund it is uh i believe it has about
1800 students
i could be wrong 9th through 12th grade
are you going to college
yes sir what are you going to study um i
think
either international business or
international law and and where will you
go
i will be at ou next year and
to take my basics and after that i'd
like to
possibly attend the university of texas
or another
school on the east coast that would
possibly have a bigger
jewish population where i could possibly
feel a little more comfortable
now how did you register where
well as a matter of fact my government
teacher
had from the beginning of the year since
there were a lot of students that were
either 18 or turning 18
she'd been pushing us along to to get
our voter registrations and
so i got mine in and sent it in and they
i think they sent me my card back about
two weeks ago so the next election i'll
be
be ready to vote thanks uh jason connor
for joining us this morning
thank you sir do you remember in 76 the
25th 26th amendment was
was law did how did you register did
they register in high school
how did it happen i i don't remember we
hear this more and more that the
teachers are bringing the rest no i was
there was no high school program i went
out and did it myself
does it what do you think about the fact
that teachers are getting kids to
register
i think it's a fine idea i have no
complaints mr tracy or
extraordinary you have to register to
vote i don't think there's any other
country where that's true most
countries if you're a citizen you're a
virgin it's one of the many many things
that seem to me to make um elections um
sorry i'll start all that again this is
one of the many barriers to having
a democratic process in this country
that the electoral college
when people think the president is
elected by popular vote and he's not
registration getting on the ballot it's
not just enough to run you can't say i'd
like to be a candidate you've got to
complete a huge number
of very onerous formalities in many
states increasingly
both parties combine to make sure third
parties can't get on
in new york state it can be you can have
a primary where the
main challenger isn't allowed on the
ballot extraordinary number of ways in
which
um the odds are weighted against the
democratic process and
and they never seem to get mentioned
yeah but the odds the obstacles are
going
down down and down motor voter being the
last sure sure i mean you
uh i mean senators used to not be
elected uh
by popular votes and uh used to you have
to
had to have sort of a fixed address and
everything to register to vote now you
can do it with a driver's license right
get a call from
los angeles good morning good morning
what are you reading this morning out
there you got the times yet
yes what do you think of this story did
you read this story on the front page
about
us okay iran arms for bosnia officials
say
i did read that uh or at least uh the
first part of it
was great interest yeah what was your
reaction is this good or bad or does it
matter
well my reaction was i was very
surprised that
it seems that american foreign policy in
bosnia
is informed by the logic and the values
of the social welfare state
that is uh the government's empty
promise to take care of you while it
degrades and diminishes
your power to take care of yourself and
instead it should be informed by the
values of uh
america's founding principles in
particular the the values of the second
amendment the legal guarantee to uh
self-defense a god-given an alienable
right
they have a surprise clinton
administration at least covertly
uh affirmed that that those values of
second amendment
i hadn't made that connection
no i must say no i'm not sure i have yet
it's ingenious though um
i must say i i'm always very impressed
by the way that
um the opponents of gun control can find
um
evidence for their view in anything at
all but like those people who can find
verses of the quran when they slice in
aubergine or pictures of the virgin mary
on clouds and so forth
i speak so as someone who very much
supports the right to keep and bear
arms but i i don't find i'm thinking
about it absolutely all the time
as as one is apparently supposed to mr
york we have a fact here from it looks
like jay tracy j period tracy of
virginia beach
does working for the spectator make you
jealous and bitter
or are these the requirements to work
for the spectator the spectator is well
represented on c-span
and i can't help but feel sorry for all
of you when you are so unhappy
jealous of uh of whom
just jealous no i don't think so besides
everybody at the spectator has just been
delighted since the clinton
administration came in it's been great
the circulation has gone up
lots of stuff to write about i think i
think it's been a pretty happy time
is this a time where you hope your
opponents win so that you can
win well as someone who's opposed to
both major parties i i certainly find
that my life is easier than being a
supporter of either one of them but i
think yes
certainly most of the intelligent people
in each party i think
realize that it can be a very good thing
for them to be defeated
las vegas good morning ryan hi angelman
uh i go along with the gentleman from
vanity fair said
one's the right cheek one's a left cheek
that's basically true with the choice
she got running
between clinton and dole i think clinton
he hasn't i don't think he's done one
thing he's he said he was doing his
campaign
except raise taxes uh since being
president
he's got certainly has no foreign policy
that's coherent
and as far as dole goes i think he's
going to follow us he's going to want to
be another reagan
that's uh age is going to play a major
factor
uh with him i don't see either one of
them as being
just the kind of president we need with
all the tensions that are mountain in
the world
uh lately north korea uh
this thing is libya uh i think we need
somebody who's gonna stand with a little
more backbone
and dole just seems to be out of you
know he's
strikes you being too grumpy and uh not
really being touched with reality
thanks you know i think uh dole is
kind of a naturally uh witty man who
seems to be doing his best for the last
four years not to say
a word i mean i think people would like
dole a bit more if he'd open himself up
but
on the other hand he might say something
like stop lying about my record and then
it would all fall which counts as a
really tough statement in this
incredibly emaciated political culture
that that's thought it was a
he stopped lying about my record shot
back mr dole you know
gosh how much more mudslinging can we
take how high can the temperature get
completely banal remark and it's thought
of as an index of real savagery
bill perkins marietta georgia says byron
york is no reporter
he's a hired verbal assassin of our
president
i have no comment uh this one is from
some place called recovery information i
think we might have missed part of it
the dole photo is being used to show his
damaged arm is no hidden horror
it puts people's mind at ease
possible
trying to re i think the photograph
there seemed to be more leg than an arm
it was a leg shot wasn't it it's both
well i don't have the photo here we
could show uh round top new york go
ahead please
yes i have a question from mr hitchens
or
not really a question more of a comment
or a statement
and it was referring to uh getting a
little nervous there
so his mention on the
trouble with the elections in this
country a little bit for
democracy and
this was a republic that uh
in its nature when you know when the
constitution was
created it was a republic and it's not
really a democracy and i was wondering
if he had a
a comment on that well
mr york corrected me i mean amplified
anyway what i was saying by saying that
obviously
there's been an evolution towards
democracy um
after all when the country was founded
some of the potential voters were
not as much not allowed to vote this
actually were allowed to be held as
property for example um it took a long
time for them to get the vote took a
long time for women to get the vote took
a long time for direct election to
the senate i like to point out that um
we're still a long way from direct
election of the president although many
people think
that's what they're getting for example
i'll give you an instance of what i mean
very very often because of the opinion
polls the where they stand now it looks
as if
mr clinton would be very easily
re-elected in the fall
but even if those opinion pearl figures
were the same in the fall doesn't mean
he'd be re-elected because of the
the waiting given to small states by the
electoral college because of the weird
way that electoral college delegates are
are selected and distributed and so
forth and um i don't know
um what should be done about it but i
think the first thing is to realize that
these obstacles exist and that this is a
very bizarre system that it is a country
where you can't just vote
by virtue of being a citizen and where
you can't just run if that's if
if we want to be as a candidate there
are all kinds of other political tests
that have to be
passed and met beforehand good morning
c-span listen to the hitchens discuss
american politics is similar to seeing
an
englishman picking his nose he really
has no merit
the itch is not being scratched
viewpoint's opinions are like most
people who display them with merit or
without
a free country permits searing freely
i don't can't read that also searing
freely also allows
for clear thinking not necessarily hand
in glove el
cluster bremen ohio
um i would be making a note of that
address i don't think
how do you ever get uh
personally angry when people criticize
you no
no i mean even if even if they're
mean-spirited uh
no i get the spectator as a matter of
fact published a letter this issue or
last or something
by a guy who wrote calling me an
ignoramus it was a terrific letter
so i kind of liked it
san diego good morning good morning mr
lamb how are you
oh i'm fine i want to say that i'm
happy that uh mr hitchens is on your
show along with the man from the
american spectator
i find mr hitchens to be
very very interesting i've seen him on
crossfire several times and book notes
but but what i
was curious is in the san diego union
it's a big story down here
they had a beating
by the police of um
some illegal aliens and
i was just wondering it seems like
the cops nowadays can't really do their
jobs i mean
i myself have had police officers pull
their guns on me
for far less and i've never cried a
police brutality or anything like this
and i was i don't know i was kind of
curious of what
uh mr hitchens and
the gentleman from the american
spectator feel thanks major
well i haven't had the police pull a gun
on me and i think it would be i'd take
it pretty seriously if uh
if they did one of the things about this
this has been played on
national and local news for the last few
days uh
played again last night when the
immigrants
filed suit but there hasn't been
much attention to the underlying
behavior which was the 70 80 mile
chase at 70 or 80 miles an hour in which
the
the cops tried to to get the truck to
stop and we're unsuccessful
well i think that's not the case because
i mean
i i know all about that it seems to me i
read it in the same story it's all a
matter of what you decide
yourself is salient about the story it
seems there was a chase the allegation
is they were throwing
stuff off the truck and the police can't
so for fact is that it's
fantastically unprofessional for any
police officer once people have stopped
put their hands on the wheel
and are sitting still to drag them out
and knock them around especially if
they're female
and you know there's there are no
circumstances in which that's
professional police behavior
facts um
investigation ron brown will the
investigation continue in any fashion
or has brown's tragic death converted a
potential felon
into saint ron the
independent council daniel pearson
announced
yesterday that the investigation into
brown himself is over
the funny thing about the brown uh
special prosecutor was that uh he was
also mandated to look into the affairs
of nalanda hill who was
brown's business partner and funneled
him hundreds of thousands of dollars
for services that are still not clear
she may be i think the only private
citizen in america with her very
own special prosecutor and the
investigation into what she did
and the money she may have defrauded
snl's out of is going to continue but
probably by a
conventional prosecutor kennesaw
georgia good good morning good morning
sir uh i was
listening to the program the other day
and i heard a guy call in about uh
kenneth starr the investigator for
whitewater that
he had had a conflict of interest in the
fact that his law firm had been
you know being investigated by the rtc
while he was investigating the rtc so i
went down the library
i found the nation magazine that it was
in i started read the article and i was
just
incredulous that uh this guy hasn't been
pulled out it also makes everything he
does
seem like it's uh uh skewed because uh
remember they removed fisk for because
they said they want to protect against
the perceptions of conflict
yet this gentleman mr starr here has
entered into a secret agreement with the
rtc to settle a case against
his own law firm doesn't that seem a
little odd to
and why is that in the american
spectator mr york
well it just uh just came out so it
hasn't been uh the spectators a monthly
but
the thing that uh i think star should do
and that he's he's done
wrong is that uh he should be doing this
full time he should have left his law
firm he should be doing it full time to
get it over quicker
and not be doing law business on behalf
of any clients right now
how much of this has the nation done on
the count of star storm
there was one big cover story about it i
think there's been a couple of follow-up
pieces
um since by murray wass
and i'm just trying to remember the
other author's name sorry um
anyway very interesting stuff thoroughly
to be recommended chico california go
ahead please
yes i had a question for the gentleman
from vanity fair
and i was we were talking earlier about
democracy on
c-span and i was wondering what he
thought about the idea of our nation
having
the opportunity to have a binding
national referendum
abiding national as as what
it wouldn't matter so much on what the
issue was but the fact that we don't
have it
maybe we should have the chance to have
that you mean any referendum
like california does exactly
can you have propositions in california
when it's not intellectual
an election year i don't think you can
can you they they have to get on the
ballot
petitions and get on the ballot since
while people are voting anyway um
that which seems to be interesting i
mean because it gives us a scope for
citizens initiative and
um and
it doesn't substitute for the electoral
process which is what i often think
people who who demand referendums are
with some part of themselves hoping to
do barony well that would kick out
200 years of reliance on the states to
do things i mean when you want to amend
the constitution
you have to do it through congress and
then through the state legislatures
and the idea of having one big up or
down vote would be
pretty much against anything that's ever
been practiced in american government
chicago you're next good morning hi
mr hitchens um it occurs to me that in
the past the catholic church was used by
the wealthy classes to keep the working
class in line
it strikes me today that people don't
have as much trust as their churches
so now we have this psychology industry
that seems to be doing this um we have
people like nathaniel brandon
big fan at the cato institute and all
these people seem to be
in the business of getting people to
believe that they're not victims and
that they're not exploited
when the simple fact is if they're
working for a capitalist
they are being exploited could you
comment please
well um exploitation in in um
in the sense in which you're using it is
moral absolute
um in other words it's just if you work
for anyone at all you're being exploited
even if you have a job actually what
exploitation means in
the original marxist schema is the is
the is the share of
the value of your work that you get back
or not
um the role of religion in in
reinforcing that uh when you say people
are losing their faith in the churches
it seems to me you're wrong
um the credulity about religion is at an
all-time high
and that the churches all seem to be
doing tremendously good business i don't
think that the therapy industry will
ever succeed in substituting
for it um i have never i've never heard
mr brandon's tapes i understand that he
was
was at one stage a leading member of the
iran movement who's
of course best known supporter and
acolyte at the moment is ellen greenspan
the federal reserve
the fact that never ceases to astonish
me why
the guy at the federal reserve is one is
the supporter of iran have you ever read
the fountainhead or atlas shrugged or
any of this stuff it's pretty
vertiginous material well when nathaniel
brennan was here for book notes a lot of
years ago
as a matter of fact this is our seventh
anniversary this week
uh we had a picture of alan greenspan
along with ayn rand
she was a part of a nine member she
called it her collective
collective yes that's bizarre well i
think mr greenspan was married to
brandon's sister or something like that
i mean he certainly is very much part of
the inner circle yes
this brian york this front page piece uh
both in i think it's in the baltimore
sun it's also in the washington post nih
that's the national institutes of health
scientists charged with abusing teen
nobel laureate has brought dozens of
boys to maryland from overseas
this is daniel carlton kadusik 72 years
old who shared a nobel prize in 76 for
research on a
new kind of organism that creates human
disease was arrested in the driveway of
his house in middletown near frederick
it's in maryland after returning home
from a trip overseas he was booked into
the frederick county jail on state
charges
involving child abuse and perverted
sexual practices and was held on
one million dollar bond any comment well
this couldn't help but attract
a lot of attention uh as i looked into
it last night he uh
he's brought a number of boys over
mostly boys over from micronesia and new
guinea
and when you look at his um who's who in
america
reference it lists 40 children
one of those has gone to the cops and
alleged that uh he abused him uh
sexually and he made some
kind of bizarre comments to local news
crews last night as he's being driven
away probably shouldn't have talked at
all
san diego you're next good morning brian
hi there
my name's mack i was wondering why the
media and especially c-span
hasn't reported upon the fact that a
young
girl was kidnapped from los angeles
driven at high speed
they crashed the border and went into
mexico
the mexican john darm pulled a
weapon and shot and killed
her and the driver is wounded
but everybody's making a big to-do about
illegal aliens
who wouldn't lie down on the ground as
ordered by
two officers who spoke both english and
spanish to the
uh uh woman and the man
did you find uh the first answer your
first question we don't know about that
here but
uh that's not why don't you check with
knsd
tv or kfmb tv here in san diego
we have a video of it well
thanks that that's why it doesn't sound
as if it has been ignored by the media
yeah well that
we don't report the news except what
happens in this town unless you call us
and that's what this is all about but
let me go to the
second point does that that do you have
do you find nothing wrong with what the
officers did there
uh in light of what happened with the
mexicans
number one you the
excerpt that the media is showing is
only the last excerpt of the video it's
not showing what led up to it
which they do have it's not showing the
six to eight cars that were run into by
the
pickup truck and it doesn't have the
sound where the officers told the man
and the woman to lie down
on the ground if the woman had stayed in
the car with her hands
on the dashboard she wouldn't have
gotten into any trouble but she tried to
get out
and get away mr york i think the
the chase story only shows excuse me the
shooting story you know shows that the
law enforcement is wilder in mexico i
don't really speak to
anything that was done in the la case is
there any way from what you know now
that you would justify what those
officers did
not the beating i think i look you can
you can try to be understanding that and
you know you listen to the police radio
and
these guys are you know all uh
completely on edge they're full of
adrenaline they finally make to stop
but uh no you can't justify beating them
like that mr hitchens
well i think we just did this
i had the impression we went through all
this a few minutes well you never know
what you're getting no
that wasn't a call from san diego as
well you may be right maybe they're
saying i'm not making this up am i we
did just do all that you know what day
this is and i did say what i thought
about
why policemen should not hit people once
they've arrested them thank you
long island i'm glad good morning
good morning uh first of all when you
first come on this morning this mr york
when the uh turkey pakistan was brought
up
he said he wasn't interested well that's
true the only thing the spectator knows
is to ant i couldn't i mean we could be
getting bombed and they'd be yelling get
clinton
get clinton and the next one is the
washington times same thing you had a
reporter on yesterday
who you questioned all the things that
he was against clinton
then you brought throw on and said that
was a balanced program
but none of those questions were asked
to that man he of course he was too
intelligent
some of the questions uh to start with
and the last point
is that when you're bringing up a uh on
his name is
imus uh brian you
you berate yourself you you act like
this giddy giddy
person so caught up i mean after all it
was your vice president
who invited him so you had a run you
made a you know a lot of attention with
that story
it wasn't color hold on it was not our
vice president that invited him uh
someone called in and at the one
moderating that day said your vice
president they asked if anybody in
c-span had anything to do with hiring
him
no no it didn't happen that way he was
why did uh
someone your program say it did someone
didn't he was invited by
the fellow who is the chairman of the
radio and television gallery his name is
ken block and he works for the mcneil
lehrer report yeah well that doesn't
surprise me
lair is completely every i stopped
watching him
used to watch him safely every night
stop watching because he's so slanted
against clinton
but the the you know even today how many
times have you brought up that one story
when you are someone out west cam
on the phone you again brought up the
story about the arms and stuff
and it was your suggestion to that man
not that man telling you what he had to
say
well it's the lead story in the los
angeles times and it's by the
washington bureau chief of los angeles
times and we sit here every day and hear
people tell us that
all those newspapers are liberals and
that they're
for bill clinton i've got a fracture
that says that all we hear from the
liberal press is pro-clinton stuff so
how do you explain that well i think
because anytime they don't like anything
said it's blamed on the liberal press if
they
even their center there it's the liberal
press and i
i don't find i find them both ways the
times
all of them let me read you this and
help help me understand this this is a
comment for
the washington journal which it says you
you lost your balance of two sides of
the issues when it's 7 am you only had
one reporter on the air
when this reporter is democratic liberal
leaning person which 80 percent are
you really get a biased view because he
is commenting on the primarily
democratic leaning print media in
washington
explain that well explain it in the way
that i didn't
if you have someone on that's completely
on the right the attacks are really
unbelievable i didn't see him attacking
he was given his opinion and i'll
respect even the rights opinion
if they're not attacking like you just
brought up the story of this man that
was
arrested well there was another story in
the other day how
uh jeff bush down in florida was on the
board of another failing bank i never
heard
anybody in c-stand bring that up you
know
uh i i know we all think towards what we
think but it's
i i was republican and i changed this
year
and my husband still is registered
republican we're in a very republican
area
but he'll never vote republican unless
they come up with someone that dole
we've watched him for years he's an he
has a nasty nasty way and anybody that
goes back a long time knows that
so i've always voted for whoever i
thought was the best
you know and i've made my mistakes i
voted for nixon
big mistake so i i really try to listen
daily but uh i just get
and i don't as i said you have an
excellent program
getting into this giddy uh gossip
mode that you get into sometimes drives
me crazy
i can get that uh with a bunch of people
when i see them out talking
brian lamb the giddy irresponsible
figure i've always been missing
something
you must be leading a life that's secret
from me i'm always very impressed when i
come on this show
um but how convinced some people are
that there is such a thing as
as a media bias in favor of one party or
another or against or for the president
i mean it seems to me
self-evident that there is there is a
tremendous bias in the media and the
biases
is in favor of bipartisanship that's
what that's what every
journalist is hoping to demonstrate and
every newspaper is trying to encourage
um that's what makes so much the
coverage
uh boring and half-hearted of course i
like the college just me and
jim lehrer on the radical right
santa barbara you're next okay
you're on good morning good morning
mike is my name good morning mike uh
it's good to get through to you good to
have you get through
all right i've just been watching your
show for the last
few months and i really like it
and appreciate it very much the last
caller
they were you know trying to indicate
that
in some way or another that you
or c-span uh
was included in the left-wing
media or did i misunderstand that
no i think she was the angie clinton
yeah the anti-clinton
media yeah it's the same argument but
made
about a different topic yeah well
the what i find about the
the right is they have
very or at least very few of them have
the ability to give an opinion
without attacking
oh and i find that true in the spectator
and it's clinton
to my way of thinking
practices the politics of community
you know they accuse him of being
wishy-washy and going back and forth
i see him coming from trying to bring
people together
where the right seems to be
divisive by its very nature
i'm confused carla you just said that
the right was able to comment on bill
clinton without attacking or with
by attacking they weren't able to give
an opinion
without attacking oh and clinton clinton
they accuse him of being wishy-washy or
going back and forth
and actually what he's trying to do is
he he's practicing the politics of
community
or bringing people together all right
thanks and we're about out of politics
it's division by definition i suppose
it's pointless saying this to people but
i mean i love it when people say
but this is the politics of division
what is politics per division
it's saying the politics of briefly it's
like saying the politics of agreement
that by definition is apolitical
here's a fact that says i love the
washington journal we hear constantly
about the liberal press
this is so how do you account for the
great press coverage of president
clinton every day for the past four
years
at this point in the game on passover
good friday i don't know what to think
if people say what do you think how can
i possibly know what to think after
sitting here listening to all these
callers
what are we supposed to think after this
well you know the left is calling him uh
is calling him wishy-washy all the time
and you know as far as attacks from the
right are concerned i mean there are
attacks i i will say the things that
i've written i think are
based in a lot of evidence i did a big
piece about reinventing government a
while back that was just
based on all the stuff i could find from
the clinton administration why did
president clinton cross the road
why because he wanted to get to the
middle
is that the last comment for this that
that if we've only got one yeah
what do you mean two days for the
weekend
i can't remember is it the weekend it's
a holiday are all days are working days
for me
i'm working on a story uh i hate to say
this about the president's insurance
policies
we are out of time excuse me byron york
is a contributing writer for the
american spectator he's a university of
alabama graduate he's a university of
chicago
masters degree holder in american
history a birmingham alabama
native a former producer for wplg in
miami and a former cnn producer 82-87
what did you do at cnn
i did everything i started like most
people do at cnn on the floor running
teleprompter and camera and then
worked up through writing and copy
editing and then producing so all these
folks standing out here we can expect
them
to be at our desk here for michelle
you're going to be over here on
at this desk with your opinion soon did
you ever think you were going to be
in the opinion business uh no but i just
it developed into a good side light
and christopher hitchens portsmouth
england
native graduate and philosophy at oxford
also uh was foreign editor with his new
statesman washington editor of harper's
at one point
is currently since uh 1981 contributing
editor
to the nation and contributing out of
vanity fair
that's it thank you very much any time
we're going to unhook you as we continue
here with open phones until the top of
the hour